thank you very much to choose to like be
here this like evening to spend
it uh together okay let's uh like do
something that it is it can be helpful
uh for everybody for us so we are going
to talk about like data processing and
uh I'm like
doing research with speech recognition
speech processing natural language
processing and of course as many like
data
scientists I am doing many like speech
processing things and uh so would like
to share how how we are doing it and uh
so uh we prepare some open source
framework for this and uh so I'm just
just uh uh briefly remind you what is
like a neuron network uh training cycle
and uh over viw our open source spech
data processor we call it is like this
and uh in uh during this I will talk
about how to do text normalization using
like U rule based text normalization and
uh like give some like basic examples
how to do data processing with uh our
predefined classes like base processor
and base parallel
processor okay and by the way if you
have any questions like please do not
hesitate maybe it could be
more uh Vivid life maybe more
interactive
okay correct so uh training cycle just
to remind you that's uh what we usually
do when we want to train our model so we
need to get data right so it comes from
a open uh internet or maybe it comes
from uh your internal uh server logs and
you take data you need to label it you
need to clean it somehow remove some
trash duplicate and so on
then if you have text uh you usually
take uh do text normalization I will
take talk about it a little bit later
and uh once it is done uh you can do
model training then model
inference uh some some kind of
evaluation interpretation of the results
and finally uh like some post processing
and as you can see uh almost each of the
step about data processing and it is
usually
like if you try to do like un
systematically it will be kind of mess
on your computer and uh uh this is a
kind of motivation why we prepare this
uh uh op Source uh framework and uh this
is about like uh bigger open source it's
about Nemo uh so um data speech data
processor is a part of uh big Nemo
project it is basically
uh uh based like based on P torch and by
torch lighting uh so we have
a uh collection of models uh like speech
recognition natural language processing
and speech synthesis and uh it of course
supports uh GPU multi node training and
uh uh multi CPU paration and U and it is
open source and it is like fully open
source because uh uh maybe you know uh
some open source project only for
research purpose but our uh uh project
for uh commercial purposes uh as
well no so uh if you don't know about it
please just uh do peep install Nemo to
it and you can work with
it and
uh so um let's move on to speech data
processor so we believe that we can like
minimize them out of bullet plate code
required and share processor steps how
we how we are doing it let's see so uh
we are organize this framework as
U
uh like python uh to Kit
with yamamo config like uh This and like
yo config is have like
central place of this
uh um framework so you uh can specify
U uh Le of processors and each processor
has parameters and uh uh like this and
uh you can run it as like bsh command so
it is like even like bsh because it's uh
you know it takes time so when you
process like big data set it usually
like takes uh not one minute maybe hours
uh or
days so it is quite convenient to run it
in some tomok or screen
right um
okay uh in this project we already uh
have uh uh quite many processors to
prepare it
prepared for instance uh rare gaps
substitution like drop uh some lines and
uh so
on uh I just listed here and I'm going
to explain some in details a little bit
but just let you know that already
prepare it like blocks inside and uh of
course you can prepare yourself uh some
processor
because uh it's like extendable open
source and uh it's uh could be based on
base processor like you can inherit and
base parallel processor I will also talk
about it a little bit more in details
but okay just let you know for
now um let's uh um look to it uh in like
let's take a example as text
normalization and uh we already have sub
regx
processor and uh uh to remind you what
is text
normalization so uh it is a process when
you work with text and uh once you have
a automatic speech recognition system uh
you will have like kind of uh letters
and usually people uh prefer this
representation with numbers right with
special symbols as door and so on right
it is easier to understand for us and
this is
like uh
less uh symbols needed right and this is
text normalization of course you if you
do uh text to speech translation you
need do reverse task and uh also we
support kind of audio based text
mization
um um like for this task we even have
like special uh project on GitHub Nemo
text processing and uh it already uh
supports a lot of languages uh but
unfortunately it doesn't support
Armenian language but
we uh uh hope that it will change we
will try
to uh do uh some work on it and uh
you're welcome to contribute as well of
course to open source and uh uh what I
want to show here that we can use
already prepared subre X processor and
specify a list of parameters and which
can do this kind of uh text
normalization uh okay okay let's take
uh where is my
cursor uh let's take
semicolon uh probably
for uh text to speech uh you want to
substitute into like just dot right for
symbol one you want to in Armenia this
Mech
right
and uh and so on and uh uh
with rules uh you also can specify test
cases I like find it very useful so uh
you can put text as input and uh how
output should be right and it will check
like it it will run this test and it is
and it will it if it is fail it will
tell you right something wrong you need
to change your
rules this is
already uh prepared
subex and so is it running test before
running Pipeline on the whole data or it
is during during pipeline yes so okay I
I will show you okay uhhuh and um we
already support a lot of data sets and
even support like
loty framework which also have has some
and I I I I'm going to use Mao common
voice because it has Armen part I I
would like to use
it today and it's quite small it is
about 5 hours and we going to extend it
basically we with our part universities
we're going to uh create events to
encourage people to contribute their
Armenian speech to like open platform it
is also open sourced
platform uh okay and this is Armenian
part
I and this is how uh date represent in
our framework it is a list of oh sorry
something wrong this should be this
should be sln as well so it's just new
line you
know uh this is a Json format right and
you have key value structure and you
have audio puff and you have duration of
this uh audio and text this is a text
from mailo common
voice um and then another Json and so on
this is how it looks like and in Maz it
use
MP3 uh audio format and uh to make it to
like you just need to install some more
libraries for M3
support
um this is how um pipeline usually looks
like so um uh you have like initial
manifests create like create inial
manifest uh processor and then I
implemented ASR like automatic speech
recognition using whisper model it's
from huging
face website and then I just filter some
using word error rate and character
error rate uh using drop
High W drop high C right processor okay
um you can check it out on our
GitHub okay uh how I uh how can you run
like ASR
processor like for this uh uh you can uh
inherit base processor class and uh you
just need to implement Constructor right
init and process that's it and uh in yo
config you need to specify like like
value of parameters of Constructor like
in our case what is it it is a
pre-trained model and output text field
right so we have name of a whisper model
they have they have about four models I
believe for now available and I used
like largest one like V2 model and the
output I save to PR text like predicted
text uh
field um that's it and this is output
manifest just come from inherited based
processor right I I not implemented
it then uh simple example with process
uh function um I just load manifest file
as adjon lists uh as I show you before
and uh then I just make sure to uh
that's a folder where I save manifest
exists right I check it out and if it is
already exist it's
okay and then I iterate our list of Json
and uh each audio file puff I put into
whisper infer function and it returns me
uh PR text and PR length it is basically
basically predicted text and predicted
language it is like language in our case
is Hy like Armenian y uh
language uh and uh that's it I just save
it as a d dictionary like with a key
value output text field and uh that's it
just Json dump and write it to the
output manifest file
is it clear
enough
great this is basically what we can do
with
this U like GPU support it's quite
simple and then we just need to do
postprocessing with drop High word error
rate and High character error rate it's
basically some metrics for speech
recognition I will not talk about it
today but hope hope it's just some error
metric
um okay uh next let me tell you like uh
base parallel processor I find it very
useful as well and because it is
parallelized on like many CPUs and the
what you need to implement is actually
process data entry it is for one uh
sample uh of data and
uh um you might
redefine prepare and uh read manifest so
prepare it is before like parallel jobs
right and read manifest also before
okay uh for this I I I took um also
Armenian data and it was a books it is
like a website when you can uh like it
is free for you to listen audiobooks in
Armenian language right and uh I
downloaded um it's and the process so I
create examples like uh create initial
manifest by extension by X and then uh
convert using ffmpeg library
to uh W format from uh MP3 then count
AIO duration then
run speech recognition using whisper as
I just showed you right and then uh make
lower case because the whisper returns
you like upper case and and other
symbols like dots commas and drop no
alphabetic and uh just some regex
for uh text normalization okay let's uh
move to uh python actually right python
code we have python meeting today right
sorry
for uh for
quotes uh by the way let me uh take a
break and ask you how many people work
with
uh with uh I I believe everybody works
with python but how many people works
with speech data I do and wow it's quite
cool so I will say it's half of audience
great
what okay
um uh let's
continue uh so we want to implement
process data entry for create initial
manifest by extension okay so what we
need to take we need to take a puff to
the folder when we will find uh files
with extensions right okay we have R
data Zer for this and also we want to
have output field to save Source like
puff to the file right and also we want
to have extension
which
we uh we we'll find this kind of
function okay I and I'm going to skip
prepare function I'm going to uh Define
read manifest and I'm going to Define
process that data
entry okay let's look at it so read
manifest uh we need
to uh find some uh any files with this
extension right it's quite simple and
then we iterate over it and uh like
add puff to it and take as a input files
we have a list of files let it and just
return list of files once we return it
uh we ready to run like uh paralized
jobs and this function will take uh one
one sample from this list just one
sample and uh okay we take this data
entry in our case it will be puff to the
file and uh save as as a d dictionary
and dictionary like
return as a like needed format data
entry uh
type that's basically
quite simple and U it's nice to have it
it it is it works
it question the second method
process is for like defining the par
work or yes yeah uh
so uh how you what data entry I can
assume that it's some custom class yes
from your site from process data entry
oh data data entry class I mean data and
yes yeah so how it paralyzed like it's
used Native uh python trades or
processes or or it's C C Level yeah
processes processes process so it should
be quite
heavy cuz you
up uh as many processes as data entry
you have oh I believe in processor you
can specify do which which do you want
to trade or processors so no
if it's Trad in terms of python it
shouldn't work like
parallel but in terms of process it it
should but the problem is that that Pro
processes is very
heavy so like you can have a lot of
process with their own trades it should
be very heavy I'm just interested if
it's trade like the se- level trade it's
another uh deal I believe it is sub uh
Library sub process Library okay it is
open source you can check it out yeah
okay okay uh but as I remember it is it
is it yeah and yes if you know how to
speed up it's like welcome to contribute
to make a PR for thank you thank you for
the
question
yeah yeah it's great to have kind of
conversation right okay uh we create uh
initial manifest and we going oh I'm
going to skip FFM convert because it's
quite boring we just run fmeg as sub
process and uh going to talk about audio
duration so um uh I want to so count
audio duration I already have audio file
puff from previous processor I want to
count duration
and that's it maybe just specify audio
output manifest file and I'm also want
to implement prepare and uh I here I
also check if uh puff like if um folder
of output manifest exists right if it is
not then I create
it and I'm going to skip read manifest
because it is inherited by uh uh from
base parallel
processor uh and maybe I missed the part
why is the file duration
is we
keep uh why the file duration is
important here why we keep it like a
additional field well this is uh how it
is implemented in our n open source and
we well we we use these fields to Define
like to understand how how how long our
process uh will take time I mean it is
like long file we need to split it up
for for instance ah like how many part
do you need to split it well this is
duration in in seconds yeah and once you
have like one hour file you cannot uh
put it directly to GPU to split to
batches yes you have to and if it is
small yeah you can okay okay
so so we uh want to uh Implement uh a
process data entry so we
take
uh uh we take dictionary as
input uh data entry take input field it
will it is audio file puff and uh read
this file using sound file library and
we take data and Sample rate and to
Define to count uh duration in seconds
we need to take shape and like divide it
to sample rate and like that's it right
and sometimes there is missing files
sometimes this broken files and so on we
need to try accept uh and U Get
return again return data entry and it is
paralized okay that's
basically about
it I'm already explained this uh
pipeline oh and uh um once we count it
we might want to V visual visualize and
understand what result we get and U we
can uh use our like tool we call the
data Explorer like speech data Explorer
and just some web
interface and um okay like you can run
it like this to specify manifest and uh
uh using this table you can like use
this filter line to like put some value
like sorted by where you you know filter
out and so on it's quite useful and uh
choose like um file like
check like which kind of words correctly
recognized and maybe correctly labeled
yeah sometimes is correctly recognized
but incorrectly labeled and or reverse
you
know
um
so let's uh conclude so we just talk
about uh uh neuron Network cycle and uh
like big part of this cycle is like data
processing and we overview like our
speech data processor uh
Library uh it is open source that is a
part
of Nemo uh toolkit and uh we
uh uh talked about text normalization
and how we can do it using uh rule based
regex uh
rules um uh explore base processor for
GPU inference uh uh with whisper model
and uh base inherit base parallel
processor for as CPU parallel wied t
tasks okay and so by writing processor
for speech data processor
we minimize amount of like template
codes right because we need to only
Implement one and just use it
in as cases by uh readable yo we share
the steps for
processing speech data set and the by
using like GPU support or CPU pariz jobs
we can speed up
it and just to remind you that it is a
part of like big uh Nemo uh project and
uh we have uh like large language models
like famous for today and like automatic
speech recognitions and other parts and
it is open for commercial purposes and
uh um you as a developers welcome to
contribute if you find some I don't know
bugs or want to have some feature in our
project thank you for your
[Applause]
time
sure are you familiar with the Nemo tool
CTC
segmentation for data processing okay oh
I'm familiar with some of CTC
segmentation tools yes
um I tried to use that tool and I tried
to integrate it with my data processing
Pipeline and uh I found it like the
boiler plate code was very like messy
and hard to uh optimize it with this
kind of flow
um do you know what are you talking
about Nemo yes Nemo there is a
uh CTC it's called CTC segmentation uh
tool for like if you have an audio uh
like 1 hour audio and big text you need
to split it up uh to little segments and
you need to uh connect it with the right
text segment mhm yeah we have two
implementations we have uh like like old
and new one and uh let's uh take contact
and
uh my question was do you think that
kind of tool would be easy to integrate
with this pipeline I believe already
integrated because uh the developer who
creates speech data processor yen is the
same who did uh Nemo Force liner too but
as I understand you didn't use Nemo
Force liner you did Force liner n force
force n Force yeah so Nemo Force liner
is a new version of CTC segmentation too
you can check it out I will thank
you uh you mentioned that uh this tool
is based on pie torch yeah under the
hood uh what about the performance uh is
it just a tool that helps with the uh
was just a boiler plate code or there is
something some
optimization um besides that uh are you
asking about speech data processor or
Nemo uh about both of them uh okay uh
Speech data processor is uh just wrapper
it's not have don't it's can optimize
let's quite you can do it can do pariz
job for you uh and uh not optimize
anything and um for Nema uh it is also
based
on py Torch lightning it's
uh and it is basically two kits for
production uh
Speech uh training and processing and it
is a not
optimize do rely on P torch right I
believe all comes from it but it has
useful features for production part of
its like I don't know uh text
normalization
right kind of
this you were talking about uh splitting
uh large AIO chunks into more smaller
ones and
in this procedure do you use some
Advanced methods G voice activity
detection or just cut it in fixed length
or maybe another
method so if uh we are talking about
Nemo force
aligner uh parts so it is
a not very familiar with it but as I
understand it uh it's uh kind of
like popular algorithm when which used
to uh used in like hien Mark of model uh
parts of it and it takes probabilities
from uh um outputs of neural network
like
CTC um loss function or maybe RN V
function and utilize these probabilities
to for in set algorithm and like trying
to find like best align alignments or
War
segments okay if I understood correctly
you run some kind of v2b alignment and
find the starts and the ends of every
word and then cut the watch audio Chun
into smaller ones yes and for V we use
output of neuron Network okay thank you
uh my question is uh do we have ability
to choose the model size like is it make
in Yolo for example or it's fixed size
and and then we have to have according
Hardware to run it mhm what is the I
mean okay if uh you want to create uh
some model from scratch and you can
choose definitely so it is uh actually
implement mented also as yo file and you
can specify which kind of layer in
neural network you want and number of
layers number of like U blocks in this
layer and so on and this is how you can
set it up okay yeah but once you use
pre-trained model it's like up to
creators that's yeah thanks I didn't
mention that uh here's a link to
Telegram and it is our local community
and we are going to publish
some uh event there and uh next event we
want to have about Armenian speech
collection and like everybody is welcome
to participate and contribute your voice
to make it larger to make it easier for
developers to create speech
uh recognition system in Armenian
language
right
yes what specifically do you work on in
Nvidia what kind of project uh are you
like yeah uh currently I uh so I'm doing
like speech uh
recognition uh things like uh train some
speech recognition models like fast
conformer
uh last models from us it like you know
it supports many languages and I trained
one of language from from
10 yeah so this is my part also we have
Ian he's working on large language model
and here I also
have can address some questions but yeah
I'm believe I quite familiar with many
parts and even I can help to find some
person who can answer Advanced question
from
[Applause]
you